there is a possibility that dr jarrah
may not lose his job as superintendent
of the clark county school district in a
major twist a school board trustee
requested a new vote after jarrah was
fired kate houston has been following
the story she's live in studio to break
down the next steps and also how that
vote might work kate yes well on october
28th the board of trustees here voted
four to three to fire jarrah now he will
still be
in his position for the next month but
now vice president irene cepeda who
originally voted to fire him is
reconsidering her decision the agenda
item as
was requested by
trustee cepela
and the other two trustees and this is
public information were trustees evelyn
garcia morales
and trustee
brooks trustee cepeda received backup to
her request from two trustees who did
not want to vote out jarrah all trustees
voices have to be heard
so as far as whether i think that that
is going to pass or not
i cannot comment on how people will vote
school board president linda cavazos who
voted to fire jarrah is now finalizing
the meeting details she says it will
most likely happen during a regular
board meeting on november 18 because
they don't have a day to schedule a
special meeting during that time two
separate votes will take place first the
trustees will hold a vote to bring the
agenda item back if that passes they'll
move forward with the vote on whether or
not jarrah will keep his position as
superintendent it would most likely take
place on the same date and you would
know that by thursday or friday of this
week i hope at the latest cavazo says
the board will have to do some
self-reflection in order to move forward
if jarrah is voted back in
i reached out to superintendent jarrah
and trustee cepeda for comment i also
reached out to ccsd for clarification on
where the two million dollars would come
from if jarrah takes them to court i
have not yet heard back to my request
denise all right kate thanks for that
update nevada governor sisalak weighing
in on troubles at the school district
the governor says he's following
everything in the news and is urging the
school board to find the right solution
for students and families in mind the
thing that you know my concern is
relates to ccsd as a kids you know
there's an awful lot of kids that are
going to school now and they need the
stability the parents need to know that
there's stability and that's what we're
going to focus on
catching up with him there at the ribbon
cutting of the new fountain blue the
governor said it might be time for
lawmakers to take another look at the
governing models of school boards in the
next legislative session